هجمات متتاليه وبوتيره متسارعه تتعرض لها
العاصمه الاوكرانيه تقول الاداره العسكريه
ان العاصمه تعرضت هذه الليله للهجوم
الحادي عشر منذ بدايه شهر مايو بمسيره
انتحاريه كما تشاهدون هذه هي اثار احدى
الاستهدافات التي تعرضت لها العاصمه
الاوكرانيه خلال هذه الليله
بمسيارات انتحاريه تقول الاداره العسكريه
ان ثماني عشره مسيره
استهدفت العاصمه الاوكرانيه تصدت لها
الدفاعات الجويه الا ان حطام هذه المسيرات
سقط في عدد من احياء العاصمه واحدث اضرارا
بالممتلكات وهذه الهجمات تاتي في ظل
تسارعا في معدل الهجمات وتنوعها بمسيارات
انتحاريه او بالصواريخ تقول ايضا الاداره
العسكريه ان هذه الهجمات هي في محاوله
لاستنزاف الدفاعات الجويه بالاضافه الى
السكان سكان العاصمه الاوكرانيه يعيشون في
حاله قلق وايضا تشير الاداره العسكريه ان
هذه الهجمات كانت تستهدف المراكز الاساسيه
في العاصمه الاوكرانيه وكنا قد رصدنا مرور
احدى المسيرات فوق ميدان الاستقلال وسط
العاصمه الاوكرانيه قبل ان تعرض تعترضها
الدفاعات الجويه اذا هي وتيره متسارعه
لهجمات متكرره نحو العاصمه الاوكرانيه